[Musique]
combien y at-il de graveurs de musique
en france
il en reste environ une quarantaine
quels sont vos arguments de travail de
branchages et même différentes roches
gravées pour la ville des titres de
nombreux thèmes la liste des éditeurs
pour les nuances de leforest grappes ans
chez les romains et accompagnant chacune
chacun savait mais celui du poinçon
ponctuation point virgule très hot 100
points d'exclamation pour une
intervention
il essayait de givre puis pour la
musique différents 3 2 contre les
rangers
les vols mecar yeahs double liège 2006
pire car des soupirs superpose le
signala cas pour les femmes les luttes
les sols de double crochet de crochets
simple le signe bis pour les nuances de
fortes et le piano la noire qui s'est
déclenchée d'autographes la blanche la
ronde le signe dakar pour et le bonheur
[Musique]
monsieur la carrière ça ne vous dérange
pas de graves et de droite à gauche ou
pas du tout après 51,1 m de métier j'ai
tellement l'habitude je serais plutôt
embarrassé pour commencer votre côté
vous n'oubliez jamais rien ça m'arrive
quelquefois j'oublie le gazole monsieur
la carrière avec ses burin et ce point
sont mettra en page aux élégantes les
arrangements les transcriptions les
oeuvres originales créées dans la fièvre
et le désordre de l'inspiration
les chefs les musiciens les chanteurs
auront devant eux des partitions lisible
[Musique]
et les militaires sont terribles avec
leur tout petit carton
gestes simples besogne fêtes en famille
l'épreuve finale ira chez l'éditeur qui
à paris ou ailleurs fera le reste
notre mère l'oie grave sur un alliage de
20 pouces en détient 80% de plomb mais
son travail est aussi durable et solide
que ce chêne que nous allions à la
sortie du village
[Musique]